Most people waste their entire life on
side hustles that sound smart but yet
magically make no money. They see AI
plastered on something and suddenly
think, well, here it is. This is the
opportunity I've been waiting my whole
life for. And honestly, I get it. AI has
genuinely changed what's possible.
[music] It has made it easier than ever
to build a profitable side hustle, but
it's also created a lot of noise. You
see, most people have no idea how to
tell the good side hustles from the bad.
They are obsessed with what sounds
futuristic, not what actually makes
money. The problem is that they think
the money is in [music] the AI itself.
It's not. AI is just a tool. The money
is in using AI to create something that
people are already paying for and using
it [music] to do it faster, cheaper, and
at scale. Just like the internet, you
don't make money with the internet. The
internet is just the infrastructure. So,
in today's video, I am ranking 17 side
hustles from S tier to absolute dog
So, that way you know which ones,
quite frankly, are just a waste of your
time. All right, so side hustle number
one, AI trading bots. This is where
people get sold the dream that a bot
will magically do all of the hard work
and generate money for them. It's the
classic this bot will print money
It is complete nonsense. Look,
yeah, sure, it might sound good on paper
to people who don't understand the risk.
But look, quite frankly, it's just
gambling with a little bit of branding
on top. It's like putting lipstick on a
pig. If you do not understand the
market, the rules, the downside, well,
then you're not building a side hustle.
You're just burning money. So, if you
want to throw your money down the drain,
congratulations, do this one. The risk
is very high with this one. This whole
thing is just a trap for beginners. So,
quite frankly, I'm putting this in F
[music] tier. And that brings us onto
side hustle number two, AI UGC. With
this one, you're going to create content
for brands using AI. Businesses pay for
this because it's tied directly to
performance. If the content helps them
sell more, well, then they'll keep
paying you to create this type of
content for them. The problem is, if it
doesn't feel authentic or if the content
doesn't perform, well, then you have a
problem on your hands. And with that
problem, you're going to struggle to
make money with this. Now, look, there
is demand, but this whole thing lives or
dies on the content and how authentic it
feels as well as how it performs. So,
because of that, I'm going to have to
put it in C tier. Now, moving on, let's
talk about AI clipping. This one I'm
seeing everywhere. With this, you're
going to turn long-form content into
shorts, reels, and clips, and you're
going to do that using AI. Now, I'll be
honest, there's actually real demand
here. It's easy to explain and it's easy
to sell to creators and businesses who
already know that they need more
distribution. The only issue is everyone
and their mom seems to be doing it,
which means the market is getting
crowded fast. And once again, if your
clips don't perform, you become
replaceable very, very quickly. Now,
look, because there's clear demand, but
very little differentiation, I'm going
to go ahead and put this in B tier. So,
just a quick note before we move on, if
you didn't already know, I've been
giving away a MacBook every video for
the last few weeks. The winner from the
last video is down [music] in the pinned
comment below this video along with the
instructions on how to claim it. And
today, I'm giving away another MacBook,
but this time the dynamic is a little
different. I'm gathering some market
research to understand what are some of
the main reasons stopping you from
starting a side hustle and how I can
help you the most. But, instead of just
guessing, I want to ask you directly.
So, I've prepared a few questions for
you that should take no longer than 2
minutes to answer. All you need to do to
enter the MacBook giveaway is click the
link in the description and answer these
questions on WhatsApp. Then, come back
here and comment on what you found most
useful from today's video. The winner
will be announced in my next video, as
always, so come back here on the next
one to check if you won. So, let's talk
about AI drop shipping. You're going to
use AI to help you source, research, and
sell products. I mean, literally just
drop shipping, but with AI layered on
top to really speed up some of the
process. The upside is the exact same as
regular drop shipping. You have low
inventory risk and it's relatively
straightforward to test products without
too much upfront commitment, but a lot
of times you're going to have to spend
money on ads, which is what gives me
anxiety for beginners. And that's really
why the core problems never change
because drop shipping really is a race
to the bottom. And AI still doesn't fix
the problems with this model, [music]
which is really bad margins and a lot of
cost to actually test products. So look,
because this is an actual legitimate
business model, it's not a gimmick, but
the cost of testing products is just too
much and I've just seen way too many
beginners get burned with this. I'm
going to go ahead and put this in C
tier. And that brings us on to side
hustle number five, which is AI voice
agents. You're actually going to go
ahead and build AI phone agents that can
actually handle calls and bookings for
businesses. And you can imagine why this
is valuable, right? Because it saves
businesses time and quite frankly, time
is money. If the agent can answer calls,
book in appointments, as well as
sometimes even go as far as to handle
basic objections, well then of course
that's something the businesses will pay
for. The setup though is not easy and
businesses get really impatient if it
becomes clunky, robotic, or breaks their
customer experience. Now, if I go ahead
and summarize this entire side hustle,
because the value is real but the
execution is more complex than most
people actually assume going into it,
I'm going to go ahead and put this in B
tier. All right, moving on number six,
AI lead generation. Quite simply, this
is where you're going to use AI to help
businesses find and qualify leads. Let's
talk about the big benefit here. This is
directly tied to revenue and that's why
businesses will always need this. So,
the demand is there, okay? If you can
put qualified prospects in front of a
business, you can make money. It's plain
and simple. With this one, you're not
really selling a nice-to-have. You are
selling something that businesses need,
okay? Something that drives revenue. So,
the value is there. The only downside is
that if your data or targeting is bad,
well then unfortunately that means your
leads are going to be bad, and the whole
thing falls apart. So, you are 100%
dependent on that. So, if I had to score
it, because it connects straight to
revenue, and it solves a real business
problem, I'm actually going to go ahead
and put it in A tier. All right, let's
talk about AI chatbots. With this one,
you are going to go ahead and build
support or sales bots for businesses.
Once again, the appeal is very obvious
with this one. It saves businesses time,
it handles repetitive questions, and it
can actually take a lot of pressure off
of the team from a business point of
perspective. But unfortunately, a lot of
these chatbots are just very gimmicky,
and it's pretending to be a business.
So, to summarize, because there is
utility, but unfortunately, a lot of it
is overhyped and really easy to
commoditize in today's day and age, and
it doesn't have that same excitement
factor as the voice agents, I'm actually
going to go ahead and put this in C
tier. Moving on, let's talk about an
interesting one, and that's actually AI
ghostwriting. With this, you're going to
use AI to help founders, creators, and
experts to write newsletters, posts,
emails, scripts, you know, whatever it
may be. And this can actually be highly
valuable if you can match the founder's
voice and strategy. Now, when you do
this properly, it can actually turn into
strong recurring revenue, because good
operators don't want one-off content.
They usually want to commit to this for
a long period of time. But, you also
need to be consistent with it to benefit
from the recurring potential of this
side hustle. Look, to be honest, if
you're just churning out content with no
thinking behind it, clients can smell
that from a mile away. And the second
they feel that, you become replaceable.
I'm actually quite conflicted on this
one, because it can go really well when
you dial in the voice and the strategy,
or it can go really bad when it just
turns into AI slop. So, because of that,
I'm actually going to go ahead and put
it in B tier. All right, moving on to
number nine, and that is AI websites.
So, with this, it's pretty easy to
understand. It just involves building
websites faster for businesses that need
an online presence. Now, the mistake
that most people make is they sell
pretty pages instead of outcomes, okay?
And the second you just sell a
nice-looking website instead of what
that website can do for the business,
well then you immediately become
commoditized. I'm actually going to go
ahead and put this in B tier. All right,
and that brings us on to number 10, AI
digital products. So, with this, very
simple, you're going to use AI to create
ebooks, templates, guides, or courses
that help people solve real problems.
This is high-leverage, it's scalable,
and it can be done completely faceless.
It's also very beginner-friendly, which
is something I value highly. Now, when
we talk about the flaws, the model only
works if the problem that you're solving
has enough demand. So, if the pain is
small, the product revenue might also be
small. But then again, I guess that's
not really a model problem, that's just
a general business problem. But what I
love about this model is just like when
you have a winner, how crazy and
scalable the business becomes. Now, I
also want to make it clear, I'm co-owner
at a company called Warp, which is a
digital product platform, and I've also
been involved in the space for a decade,
so I do want to say I have some bias
towards this. But all in all, I've seen
people make crazy money as a side hustle
all the way into the millions and
millions of dollars, which is why for
me, because of the scalability of this
business model, I'm going to go ahead
and put it in S tier. All right, moving
on, side hustle 11, AI apps. Now, with
this side hustle, you're actually going
to use AI to create software apps
faster, and the way you're going to do
that is by reducing coding and product
building time. We live in a cool world
where this actually possible, and
there's actually good upside here if the
app actually solves a real problem and
people keep paying to use it. The issue
is that most beginners confuse building
an app with building a business, and
that is a very expensive mistake. An app
is just a product, the business is
distribution, retention, and
monetization. Now, because the upside is
big, but the execution and then managing
churn, and just the general business
model is very tricky as someone who's in
it myself, I'm going to go ahead and put
this one in B tier. All right, moving
on, this is actually a blast from the
past for me. This is AI meme pages. So,
what you're going to do here is you're
going to grow meme pages using
AI-generated or AI-assisted content, and
then actually monetizing later through
uh brand deals or paid shout-outs or
even affiliate stuff like that. And the
reason I say this a blast from the past
is this is actually probably my first,
if not one of my first side hustles.
When I was 14 years old, I actually had
my own Instagram accounts where I was
doing this. Now, they weren't meme
pages, they were branded pages, and they
were all like sort of motivational
luxury lifestyle pages. And back then, I
also didn't have AI to help me, and that
opens up a lot of opportunities, okay?
Now, with AI, it is cheap to start, and
if the content is genuinely good, it can
grow. Attention is fickle, and the
content being good is a big if, okay?
Most pages never actually amount to any
money. So, because it's easy to start,
but also really difficult to turn into a
serious business, I'm going to go ahead
and put this in D tier. All right,
moving on, AI faceless YouTube channels.
With this, you're going to use AI to
script, voice, and produce videos
without ever showing your face. It's
scalable, you don't need to show your
face or build a personal brand, which of
course makes it very appealing for
people who want leverage without having
to be the product. The problem with this
is that it's very slow to monetize, and
most people quit before they make any
money here. The grind looks simple from
the outside, but the patience
requirements, most people unfortunately
just can't handle it. So, if I had to
summarize it, because the model has some
leverage, but the timeline is just too
long, and most people don't stay in it
long enough to see results,
unfortunately I'm going to have to go
ahead and put this in C tier. All right,
moving on, AI video editing. Very
simple, you're going to use AI tools to
cut, edit, and repurpose videos for
creators and brands. The demand exists,
it's fast to deliver, and it is
relatively easy to productize if you're
efficient and you can get moving
quickly. Issue is the barrier to entry
is very, very low. So, the market gets
flooded with people offering the same
copy-paste BS, and because of that,
clients are always going to compare you
based on price instead of value, and the
issue with this is that it quickly
becomes a race to the bottom. So,
because it's easy to sell, but it's also
easy to copy, I'm going to go ahead and
have to put this in C tier. All right,
number 15, AI print on demand. Very
simple, you are going to use AI to
generate designs and then you're going
to sell them on shirts, on mugs, on
posters, stuff like that. Once again,
it's very low upfront cost and it is
simple to test. So, it looks attractive
to beginners who want to get started
fast. The problem is with this one, you
have no moat, the competition is brutal,
and most stores die in the first few
weeks or months. So, to summarize, it's
easy to launch, but it's hard to build
it into anything durable. I'd say really
this one is more of a gimmick than
anything. I will put it in F tier, don't
waste your time. Now, let's move on to
something that is not a gimmick, but
also has some of its own downsides, I
guess like every model, and that is AI
automation agency. Simple concept, this
is where you're going to build systems
that replace boring, [music] repetitive
work for businesses. Once again, the
demand is there, okay? And there's a
real high-ticket potential if you are
solving problems that actually save
time, make things more efficient, and
reduce the need for businesses to hire
more people. Where the downsides come in
is the delivery can get messy, and you
will need some operational skill because
once you start playing with internal
systems, things can get tricky. So, to
summarize, the need is real and the
upside is there, but the execution can
get tricky at times. Nonetheless, I'm
going to go ahead and put this in A
tier. All right, and that brings us on
to number 17, and this is AI prompts.
Very simple, you're going to sell prompt
bundles for different use cases. It's
easy to create and it's easy to package.
So, on the surface, it looks like a
solid side hustle, but look, there's no
moat, the perceived value is low, and
most of it is just AI slop if we're
being entirely honest. Anyone can make
prompts, which means no one really cares
about this too much. So, look, because
it's easy to produce, but also very hard
to make valuable, I'm going to go ahead
and put this in D tier. All right, so
there we have it, 17 side hustles ranked
so that way you don't need to. The
bottom line is this, AI is not the
business. Get that through your head. It
is simply leverage. So, whenever you see
a new AI opportunity, stop asking, "Oh,
is this cool?" And instead ask, "Can
this solve a real problem people already
have and make me money as a byproduct?"
If the answer is yes, pay attention
[music] to it. But of course, do your
own research. If the answer is no, well
then don't waste your time. As a general
rule of thumb, anything that's make
money with AI by selling AI or let the
bot trade for you is usually
The best side hustles are the ones where
AI helps you save time, create assets,
or deliver a real outcome to the buyer.
It's generally business models that
existed before AI, but now what AI
allows you to do is do it faster,
cheaper, quicker, or it allows people
that historically were not able to get
into the business model because the
barrier to entry was too high, and now
they're allowed to do so. And when you
think about it like that, that is how
you stop chasing shiny objects and start
building a real profitable side hustle.
And with all that being said, as always,
I'm watching from afar and I'm rooting
for you.